yeah hello and welcome to this video on
playing Ferrari Ferrari is probably
better right 2017 I'm back home
recording video was hope that works like
technically speaking with a different
setup of course and home so I've got um
Scottish war nights here on the border
c5 there must be a mouse lip basically
and then let's give him the take back
like c5 makes the game kind of worthless
if it gave me yeah
okay so h3 here is my continuation
that's generally useful move Queen f3
years prepared you know c6 is the most
common reprieve at age six is also seen
can still play c6 no white a main idea
in this type of position is to play the
move c4 and try to further weaken blacks
poor information after c4 like does not
want to take isolating the C pawn on the
other hand white my to take on d5 and we
get another isolated pawn so C was a
generally desirable pawn structure
change let's see what happens here I
have to be aware of rook shakes too
sometimes
this move is possible but not at this
particular moment it would be an idea if
there be more pressure on here for so c4
is part of my strategy so let's do it
I'm not short blacks best reply as him
yeah I was just about to suggest this
and it looks like a decent decent way of
playing I'm trying to use this
opposition Queen and rook it's very very
likely reply relay ninety-four is
interesting now adding an additional
pressure on c6
and now how do we do that I wonder if I
should actually capture on e6 I mean I
have an advantage if I take that I mean
yes to check with the F pond mmm
still not sure if it is enough or if I
have something better and this is also
possible threatening okay it's a very
crude threat button I'd f5 yeah he has
to take care of it okay that move I did
not consider Oh interesting
what about Knight f5 now is it an idea
and then trying to check on the kingside
I have a have some some some pieces
they're really interesting one thing is
also even move the rook and this Bishop
c3 coming it's a bit of a problem
[Music]
that's d4 and do got a one is hanging
okay so let's go for it
I expect yeah maybe he's going to dat
which could be better could be better
yeah to the edge keeping f6 protected
yeah so it's a little bit difficult here
let's see rookie - maybe just rookie -
and I takes aged six I don't think it's
working or here yeah I should play
quicker this was one thing that's
definitely true night xh6 was
interesting but I think takes Bishop
takes Bishop evades defended
it's a surprising choice
when surprising
not sure that this is such a yeah no I'm
no I'm taking her and what no question
about that
goodnight now it's hanging and queen g3
is on mmm that looks bad right well what
does he have the night doesn't even have
a square yeah okay this one but shake
Queen f6 is a bit of a disaster bishop
f8 how do you win against that probably
taking and then rookie 5 yeah yeah
yeah he has to take with the rook yes to
take with the rook here and then rupee
five should win 25 even is a maid yeah
okay
at caesium I only saw the a slower one
but there is obviously a maid I was
really irritated but there should be
form so roughly here it's a position
that is some probably known to theory
I'm not entirely sure but it looks very
standard there should be six now the
ideas he wants to take with this and now
I don't even have a good square for the
Queen eeeh for example here this not h5
for example is way there's only 23 and
then 9 h5 is good for black so I'm
keeping the tension 94 here rook e1 was
actually good move
and here rookie 2 is preferred by the
computer
yeah maybe what I underestimated I said
after Bishop c3 actually I can take huh
oh that's true actually like take bishop
a one that's not g7 and here I have Luke
c1 which looks good yeah okay so my
Knight f5 was not a good good choice I
had a real blunder and I'm curious what
that was Queen d8 was my blunder
later
oh it says one blunder on my engine and
I don't know what it is I mean I
definitely didn't play although all the
best movers but still okay Knight f5
Queen d8 okay Queen f8 a stronger
interesting
huh my dad Bishop takes age 600 dead
it's a blunder rookie is free okay
I have Bishop age six okay I didn't
think about that move I mean this is
fairly clear but this one I thought but
I can take hi that that's interesting
Makia I'm attacking this so this is
indirectly protected interesting and
Knight takes Queen cheeks so also that's
just a draw hmm so then what's so great
about Bishop h6 of Zed is to draw
funny computer line I went droopy 3d for
two ends is good for y yeah should be
good for white and now night h6 is given
as a blunder
yeah well that h6 is come really winning
here so it's not a blunder
now g7 is supposed to be stronger okay
nobody can this is winning this is
hanging and I have the Queen g3 threat
and black cannot defend that is not a
blunder it's lost anyway after that
we've got meat meat coming up yeah okay
I didn't play perfectly but it was okay
after a longer break thanks a lot for
watching